dès le début le gouvernement a affiché
une méthode celle ci est de poser des
hypothèses de recueillir des réactions
et notamment celle du parlement de
l'aude en tenir compte pour de nouvelles
hypothèses de revenir devant
et de continuer ainsi à préciser les
choses c'est exactement ce qui se passe
tout au long du mois d'avril un point
clé était le discours du premier
ministre hier et nous avons encore du
travail sur certaines précisions
comme nous l'avons fait ce matin avec
les associations d'élus comme nous le
faisons en vous écoutant si vous avez
des solutions sur certains des points
néanmoins maintenant le degré de
précision est assez fort sur les trois
domaines que j'ai déjà évoqué c'est à
dire le protocole sanitaire sur le
protocole sanitaire vous avez une
réponse sur chacun des points que vous
avez mentionné cantine internat à cour
de récréation abords des établissements
tout ceci est réglée sera une référence
nationale et donc je crois que c'est
très clair sur le sujet du décrochage et
de la lutte contre le décrochage
je crois que votre parti parle de
d'obligation scolaire j'en déduis que
vous prenez l'idée que nous allions
chercher les enfants dans les familles
nous les emmenons à l'école même si les
familles ne veulent pas ce serait tout
simplement pas applicable donc soyons
raisonnables j'ai entendu dire
cacophonie aussi parce que le président
aurait dit quelque chose de différent de
ce que j'aurais dit c'est faux le
président a dit exactement ce que
j'avais commencé a annoncé précédemment
à l'assemblée nationale c'est à dire le
fait que en réalité la seule chose que
l'on peut dire dans de telles
circonstances c'est à dire l'instruction
est obligatoire si elle est obligatoire
ça signifie que soit l'élève va à
l'école physiquement ce que nous
souhaitons soit il ya un enseignement à
distance garantie et oui notre priorité
sera d'aller chercher au maximum ses 4 %
des élèves décrocheurs que nous avons
eues pendant le confinement ce qui au
passage est un des meilleurs chiffres
d'europe c'est encore trop élevé et
c'est un des meilleurs chiffres
aujourd'hui
et puis enfin en troisième lieu vous
vous demandez comment va être comment va
s'organiser la communication avec les
familles j'ai commencé à le dire nous
allons être très attentifs à ça il faut
une personnalisation des parcours
ce que nous voulons c'est qu'il y ait
sorte de feuille de route niveau par
niveau élèves par élève pour le mois de
mai et juin parce que oui ce mois de mai
juin 2020 est forcément très différent
de tout ce que nous avons connu et nous
sommes en ce moment en train de le co
construire avec tous les acteurs non
seulement de l'éducation mais de la
société française je vous remercie